so
i'm with my daughter last night in the
kitchen she's gonna be 10. and um she's
like oh my god i can't believe the host
of jeopardy is coming on your show
and i was like oh my god if you only
knew like we've known you through so
many iterations how does it feel
to now wear this new crown
and doesn't it actually matriculate back
to your son as an origin point so for
jeopardy you know this is like i mean
you you've experienced these as well
things that you did not plan that
happened and then change your life
yeah and um my son uh was you know on
the internet like they tend to be and he
said mama people are saying you should
guest host jeopardy and this is when
jeopardy was having guest hosts um after
alex trebek passed away and i said
that's not true and he said they they
said they're saying it on social media
so i called my agent i called richard
weitz and i said my son said that he saw
something on social media that i should
guest host jeopardy and richard white
was like i'm on it i'm on it and i said
but are you really like
why is my son the first one to anyway
richard white then called me a couple
weeks later and he's like you're gonna
guest so is jeopardy so that's how that
started and through you know a series of
twists and turns and you know
fascinating things i ended up with more
than just a guest hosting gig and i was
i already have a full-time job i'm on a
show called call me cat we're doing our
second season so i have a full-time job
we talked about that
and and i'm you know i've been balancing
these things for about a year you know
we're finishing our second season of
call me cat and then jeopardy happened
and then
i wrote this script you know six years
ago and never thought it would turn into
a movie and just everything happened
this year is what happened so last
summer it was you know pre-vaccination
we filmed this movie
um with dustin hoffman and candice
bergen and diana agron and simon halberd
i mean
they do say and i really love this
saying so much that i actually wrote out
a neon sign and created it and made it
with this company and i hung it in my
entryway and it says timing is
everything yep
um so all of this was incubating
and the time obviously is now talk to me
about this movie why did you write it
six years ago why is it personal for you
how did you get this cast
the last one i'm still trying to figure
out it feels very very surreal um about
my father died seven years ago and
there's a traditional year of mourning
in in observant judaism and after that
year a lot of things kind of tend to
open up it's a very kind of closed year
and are you sitting shiva that whole so
no you sit shiva for for seven days but
there are restrictions in traditional
judaism for the year um i didn't listen
to music for a year there are certain
events you don't go to it's there's a
lot of very elaborate things that are
meant to sort of make it a year of focus
and introspection indeed it was but when
that year ended
i felt a desire to write and to write
out thoughts and memories and a lot of
music was coming to me from my childhood
i never thought i'm gonna turn this into
a movie i just thought well i'm a writer
and i better put it down on paper i sat
on it for a long time finally got the
courage to show it to a few people close
to me and i sent the script never
thinking that i would get these actors
and simon helberg i knew from big bang
theory yeah i thought he'd say well miam
that's very sweet and i remember when
your father passed away and i'm sorry
but he wanted to do it and dustin and
candace and diana they all said we feel
very moved by this script and dustin was
not a fan of big bang theory which is
fine he had never seen it i think and he
said how'd you get into directing miss
bialik i said well funny thing mr
hoffman this is the first thing i've
ever written and he said that's not true
and i said yes it is
and he did the movie and really really
felt moved by
the story and seeing him and candace
together was absolutely incredible i'm
so glad that you turned it into this
beautiful movie that is so gorgeous it
really sweeps you off your feet and it's
again why the dustin hoffman's and the
canvas bergens are like sure it's like
they're the best actors they know good
thank you congratulations i appreciate
that very much
[Applause]
[Music]